um i've always been fascinated by the
american world and i traveled
a lot um and uh when we first when i
first read jessica's book
and it was incredible to know how big
the community
and how colorful the characters are in
there and how amazing their
experiences are so i wanted to capture
that we start with
a set of rules before the film started
there's only three lenses we're going to
use there's only a certain time of day
there's there's a bible you know the
dogma but there's a
there's a ten commitment we must follow
and then once those things are set in
stone when you show up on set
everything is completely different than
you expected
well i i think fern is at her core is me
at my core
i think something that chloe was
attracted to in the time that we spent
together
is that there's a childlike quality that
we were really interested in for fern
that she's had a very prescribed
set of rules living in empire and
once she hits the road the possibilities
become open
and her sense of self-sufficiency is
tested
well from the very beginning we wanted
fern to be a guide
to be able to bring us into this vast uh
really rich world of nomadic living what
i've learned that you have to anchor the
audience
in one person's intimate experience so
they can feel
you know comfortable to be able to
experience everything else
and without getting lost so that's
always the plan from the beginning to
find that balance
you know fern takes care of herself and
you're always wondering
but she has such such warmth that she is
a nurturing presence
it's just like oh that's everybody's mom
it's just like
everybody's mom i'm in the business of
recording
time in a way is uh what i mean by that
is
some people aren't going to be around in
10 years some places
are going to disappear in 10 years like
when i drive through a little town in
nebraska there used to be something when
the railroad was there but now the
railroad closed and there's
five people living there it always made
me think how do they want to be
remembered
and it is not about me going in to say
to the nomads
i have an idea of how the world should
be
and i want you to help me to make the
world a better place
that is not my job as a filmmaker i
my job is to go in there and ask them
how would you like to be remembered
and and work on my film from that
direction
and as time goes on i realized that it
actually all started with the final
image
the image that was in jessica buddha's
book because in the book
linda mae was left alone she found some
land and she stood there alone
and the jessica wondered i wonder what
ways for linda may you know where she go
from here and that ending of the book
was so profound to me
and seeing this woman left along in this
ragged wilderness
having made the choice she made not to
live this way and and
and or not trust first but then
eventually become a choice
i i um i realized that's how i wanted
the film to end
you know and then from fern alone in the
wilderness
not staying behind on the homestead from
most westerns
but she is the one that now walking into
the wilderness and
going backwards is how to create a
character arc
emotional arc strong enough to hold the
audience so that last moment
the audience would feel how i felt when
i read the book
the tone thing i i don't think i
ever think about it and and but i i
notice it when
it's definitely totally all over the
place i can recognize when he's
a cocktail and then but but for some
reason you know they say like
life isn't perfect the beauty is isn't
is in making it yours you know and
i find that for certain type of
filmmaking by the way it doesn't apply
to all
but in in what i'm trying to do um
if someone's giving you something or if
something happened on set
and you capture it is is a bit of it
feels
damaging to try to get rid of it in
service of a consistent tone
um and that's in in the edit really for
me when
when when you screen it for people i
usually get notes totally this is all
over the place
and then you have to make a decision
whether you want to keep it that way or
not
you know in this moment fern had just
left where she's from which is northern
nevada
to the desert in corset arizona
where there's a gathering of nomads and
land dwellers
called the rapper trump rendezvous the
rtr
i like the kind of video games where you
just walk through beautiful landscapes
so we talked a lot about video games and
then how
immersive it is and to just follow a
character and walking through this space
and the camera drifts and there's a lot
to discover in the frame
so that's the conception of this shot
and rdp is really good at calculating
the exact time of day
where the sun is in the right place if
the sun is any higher
you would have blow things up the sky
wouldn't be the same
if it's any lower you would lose details
on what was in front of it and this was
one
take that's it you can really only do
one take
every day which is having an incredible
producing team
organizing everything killing everyone
off camera
and then our sound design team just
rebuild the entire soundscape
but there's that one scene where she
sits down with homeboy
she's like you know i bet your parents
an issue and that scene it just
tore it just tore my heart out i mean
derek
uh honestly that's how he is in in real
life it's like he
he came from another era i feel like he
is like a um
huckleberry fan or something you know
and he's really happy
just being out there alone in the desert
hop off a train and just sit there for
days
every location we go to there is going
to be people
of that land that should be used
representing that place
so we cast as we went and people like
derek
i met in the desert it depends how
what's your style of working with prof
known for
professional actors you know there are
ways to work with non-professional
actors you create a role
a character that has a bit more plot
points and
and you require a bit more
depth um in in terms of how much they
evolve
and and you you go do a big casting call
and then you find someone who will be on
their way to become a professional actor
someday
and you rehearse them you train them and
you do it
but that's what not what we were
interested in right we wanted people
that can just play a version of
themselves
and give us that sense of their own real
life and
so then the characters that i would make
a fictional are the characters that i i
need to create an
arc that's very far from the reality
that could help me incorporate
all these real people in it and those
are cast by uh with professional actors
the improvisational thing um yes there's
about five percent of the film
is we do we just find in a moment but
most of them are if not a few days
before
uh i have met someone and then i would
still
write scenes for them the same process
talking to the right scenes and so they
get pages
um on the day i learned that from uh
from my first film which i shot without
a script it was a big mistake because
don't shoot a film with a treatment at
least that's what my advice would be
because treatment makes sense sometimes
because those
between the paragraphs some of these
things that will present itself in the
script format
you're missing scenes you will be
realized that you're missing things that
connects
some of the things in the treatment even
if i knew
most likely this person is going to
improvise i still
write the scene for them so i know
there's a shoe box if i'll have nothing
works i can always pull out my script
and say this is this is why i'm doing
this
you know to me i think the the the trick
the the thing that we strive to is try
to
um plan as much as possible to a point
when
when you can feel as if when you watch
the movie
that we just showed up and did it yeah
and we don't mind people feeling like
well it's a little
you know a little sad when they think
that but but that's what we want them to
feel
uh basically actually you need all the
planning in the world to to make that
happen
and to make that happen you need to plan
probably three times even more than a
conventional shoe
because you want you need to plan every
possible reactionary situation
when you do be spontaneous while you're
on set
and and to be able to then drop someone
like francis mcdormand
in the middle of that that kind of
immersive reality with the nomads then
that's when you get that feeling
they feel extremely human these
characters uh and the experiences of
people in these places feels extremely
human
we want we try really hard um to
tell a story where the audiences can
come in doesn't matter what they believe
in what political party they belong in
they can relate on a human level first
and then they can take the judgment of
they can walk away feeling however they
want to feel that's we're not
here to teach we're here to hopefully uh
communicate and
and make you feel something uh you know
obviously i have
my own opinions my own political
opinions and
opinions in general but i learned very
early on
it's not really my job to to make
films to try to convince other people of
my own
political opinion it's my job is to
create a a human experience
for my audience and so that they could
step in
to a world that's not their own and meet
people they would never
meet and connect and then they can walk
away make their own decisions
so so then that means that when i do go
into some a stranger's home
i'm not trying to tell them how they
should live
and what i think their politics or tell
them about my politics and tell them
what's right or wrong about the world um
i i know later this year you have
marvel's eternals coming out and you
know
you look at the two different films
coming out this year two completely
opposite ends of the spectrum
but i'm curious uh sort of what is the
most interesting sort of commonality
between a smaller more quiet movie like
nomad land and then obviously sort of
the big
marvel movie like eternals um i think
the way that we're making it really you
know
is um um i have a incredibly supportive
team on both
films and uh we're using the same camera
rig
same very similar uh choices yeah
um and then and then i'm working with 25
27 people on normal land
closely and then on internals those 25
people might have
hundreds of people behind them but
that's still my core
that are very protective of me so my own
experience hasn't really changed that
much that's the only
thing i can say that is similar
you know it's like we have all got into
a boat
together and went on a sailing trip
and yes i'm the captain but
it's a matter of survival when you're
out there
you know we all every day looking at the
song setting
we need water now we need to find
bathroom and now the storm is coming you
know
being out there uh uh in this landscape
on the road
we were all we needed each other we
needed
each other and i think that's what what
how the bound is formed that's how we
learn to trust each other and work
together
you